welcome to council geeks my name is the
thing away and I'm joined tonight by
polsku Vito and we are going to be
debating a topic that I actually haven't
gotten to talk about on this channel
before and that is video game movies and
the reason it's the two of us is I'm
gonna make the case that I don't think
they're ever gonna get good and he's
gonna argue with me he'll be wrong he
always is video game movies yeah there
are many good ones can we at least agree
that of the ones made so far the best
they've managed to be as entertaining
none could truly be called good movies
or do you want to make a case for
anything that's been put out so far not
really oh come to so we're not here to
do what about the past we're talking
about the possibilities of what the
future holds or what it could hold is
there really a future now I suppose we
can deal with the most immediate thing
which is that there are actually four
video game movies coming up this year
one has already come out ratchet and
clank and made a complete non splash yep
gang grievers yep which I suspect will
make decent money and probably be in
offensive if we're gonna use something
like Angry Birds as an example of a
video game movie you know what is the
story behind Angry Birds right even if
Angry Birds does okay they're not going
to hold that up buzz Oh video game
movies are not legit they just won't
because not enough people take animation
seriously so the ones that everyone's
eyes are on our Warcraft yep and
Assassin's Creed yes how hopeful are you
for either of these well the world of
warcraft let's just start with that one
okay i think part of the problems that
this is actually just not a good trailer
and the reason it's not a good trailers
because it actually told us the entire
film which is that the you know there is
a conflict between these two kingdoms
the human Kingdom and the orc kingdom
but then there's a bigger threat and
they have to work together to face the
bigger threat I think it's gonna be fine
I also think this is about 10 years too
late I don't have
for fine well that's enough copy video
game movies have topped out at fine they
need a kick in the butt of something
that is greater than fine so if we're
not expecting that from Warcraft what
about assassins creed for those of you
not familiar with the with the games of
Assassin's Creed the basic premise is
that your main character that you play
is being forced into his own genetic
past his family was a family of
assassins and he's basically recreating
their most historic kills throughout
years there's a lot to like about the
assassin creeds property and at its
heart it's a story about assassins
versus this group call that the Templars
Knights knights of templar i think that
the Assassin's Creed property has an
almost limitless possibility in terms of
the stories that you can tell they have
changed the animus which is for the fans
people not familiar again the animus was
the mechanism through which you entered
these genetic memory they made it much
they basically gave it a physical
feedback aspect they did and and so that
I mean my gut so the hats different and
weird and I don't like it but I'm
willing to forgive and let it see I mean
it looks kind of cool as someone who has
not actually played the assassin Korean
but is familiar with them and is
familiar with the lore and is familiar
with people's reactions you know what
ones in the series they consider good
what ones aren't so good yep I find it
odd that they're even sticking with the
entire animus conceit if you use that
conceit then what will the stakes be
because if all of the action takes place
in a past where we know everybody is
already dead and the most that we can
see is just how the how the dominoes
fall for whatever reason they're putting
him back in it maybe there can be stakes
involved in that but it's hard to build
stakes off that now the games get away
with it because you as the player get
the visceral thrill of getting to
control the characters leaping off of
buildings and fascinating someone with a
hidden blade and all that but you remove
the fact that you get to do that
yourself and what are actually the
stakes for anything set in the past my
guess is that what's going to happen is
it's going to be much like new players
with the game in that he is probably not
going to be very good at it at first and
so I mean he's gonna mess up in his own
memories and in these own genetic
memories and he'll stumble he'll get
caught he'll get arrested he'll get
killed and what would add the stage to
that is there's probably going to be
some kind of smoking gun to his head
we've got your kids or your family or
your dog um and we're gonna do things
sort of leaping off from from what I
said sort of one of my big concerns with
with any adaptation I think once you
strip out the interactivity most of
these games don't have particularly good
stories or at the very least don't have
stories that have not already been told
in the film medium in some way like a
games series that i love is uncharted
which is cinematic as heck but the
minute you take out the fact that you're
the one getting to control it then all
you've got is in indiana jones knockoff
I won't argue that point I think that
they would make I think they essentially
are films for 30 our films well then
well then that's sort of the other thing
because I I suspect your problem I may
be jumping you had it you had hinted
that you might be bringing a bioshock
sure in this argument yep all right
better check among many others if you're
trying to adapt the original bioshock
into a film or even the newer one I
think you're going to have a challenge
and I think that if you're trying to be
true to the source material inside of
those games and the experience and the
immersion and the the way that those
stories kind of pull out like you know
you know I'm thinking of things like
dead space right you know where the
terror builds over you know 20 and 30
hours yeah that's going to be difficult
to recreate that's that sort of
experience I think the and you would
have to do it in a place like HBO or
Showtime where they could spend the
money well that sort of thing
it if I wouldn't even be having this
argument if rather than trying to make
movies they were trying to make
miniseries sure i would i would go
awesome one of these is going to be
great but the fact that they are
insisting on film yep and insisting on
condensing them down two to two and a
half hours I think creates a big problem
whether you doing a direct adaptation to
the story or if you're doing a based on
which appears to be kind of what
Assassin's Creed is doing is they're not
directly adapting any and they're not
even using a setting they've done before
the games i'm done Spanish Inquisition
before so that is more of a based on
than a direct adaptation but we're
growing some which is why you go with
something like Bioshock or even most of
the examples that you cited dead space
would would be another one a big part of
why those games grab people as much as
they do is the atmosphere but the thing
is the reason the atmosphere works is
because you get to just dwell in it and
you get to experience it at your own
pace you get to wander through and
absorb through strictly you know direct
visual storytelling how you know to use
Bioshock how rapture is falling apart
and how it got there you get to
experience that in whatever degree you
want to because you don't have to go
around and look at everything but you're
choosing your level of immersion and you
can really get absorbed in that and it
does create an incredibly deep story any
attempt to take that kind of atmospheric
experience and cram it into two hours
the best you're going to get is the
Silent Hill movie which did visually
recreate the atmosphere of the Silent
Hill games very well but it was nowhere
near as impactful because wandering
through that town for hours on end will
always just have a much more lasting
experience than being led by the hand
for two hours through the condensed
version if you're I mean some of my
favorite storytelling experiences have
been in video games and I would point to
the last of us I would point to bioshock
i would point to half-life 2 I think the
mediums have a hard time with each other
they have a heart because they are
inherently
different storytelling mechanisms yeah
you know in it so that's why when you
take something like Street Fighter right
which is just a fighting game that has
as much you know story on it as there is
you know you know bubbles and skim milk
take that metaphor there's really
nothing there but again I mean
theoretically that should give you
almost limitless freedom to tell
whatever kind of story you gotten you
could get a pirates of the caribbean
right which i would argue is a good
movie um you know in all the ways that i
would measure a good film well i think
this is actually where the Super Mario
Brothers movie ruined it for everybody
which is that I i would say that there
was a window where we could have gotten
good movies but what needed to happen is
basically what happened with super mario
brothers but with a creative team that
was not insane because what happened
with Super Mario Brothers was basically
Nintendo said look here's the stuff here
are the tropes here's that here's a list
of characters and things do whatever you
want and they did but what they wanted
to do make no sense him was insane but
but crime against children yes it was it
was horrible but if and and by doing
that it completely scared off everybody
from that method of look just take the
bits and pieces and craft something new
with it now everyone's too afraid to
ever do that because they needed thought
is Super Mario Brothers movie yeah and I
think that book before that window
closed that would have been the way to
do it and I think part of the reason
we're not going to get a good video game
movie or at least not for a very long
time is because the mentality because
right now it feels like they're trying
to approach video game movies like they
have started approaching comic book
movies which is that we got to stay true
to the source material we got to go back
to the roots and we got to honor it but
the problem is is that comic books lend
themselves much better to direct screen
adaptations than video games do because
the differences in the medium and what
qualifies as good storytelling are so
drastically different and I'm certainly
not making any of those arguments of
video games are not
they're not just know you can tell
brilliant video games and stories in
video games but because a good video
game story hinges on the interactivity
as as being a big part of the mechanism
for why the story works I don't think
you're going to create the same type of
immersion or feeling even in a film that
you're getting get from a video game I I
just don't think that's possible as I
don't think you should and I think that
the I don't think that should even be
something you attempt you can tell a
story in that universe please do but
don't try to recreate the gaming
experience mhm um in a film I don't I
don't want that I don't want other
people to be subjected to that you and I
think actually some of the best voice
acting is actually happening within the
world of video games and you know I
there are some you know I could point to
knights of the old republic Grand Theft
Auto games in terms of the acting that
happens within those various parts LA
noire would be another example sort of
where I've landed on kind of a
philosophical level that makes me feel
that it's a from a from a creative
stance forget financial eventually
they'll find a way to crack it and start
actually making money off these things
but from a creative stands why it's kind
of a dead end and I'm going to start in
the form of a question what does a story
that has already been told as a video
game assuming it was told well as an
opinion what does that story gain by
being adapted to film when you would
that pretty much anything you lose
something you gain some sure so when you
adapt a novel generally what you lose is
the author's voice and by that I don't
mean I don't mean die along the way
people speak I mean the words that they
chose to describe things create a unique
narrative voice yeah you ain't any
Stephen King yeah filmer so if you lose
that and you gain actually being able to
see in the visual representation of that
yeah in comic books you lose a certain
garishness because there are certain
things that you can certain costumes for
example you can only get away with if
there is still image and they don't have
to move or you know certain age you know
people who know how to use panel
progression really well or whatever but
what you gain is you gain actual phone
when you gain an actor's interpretation
so you get a definitive way that those
words are being said and it's not only
in your head when you adapt a video game
especially video games in the state
there and now which have good actors and
good motion capture and even in some
cases a-list celebrity actors appearing
in the video games when you adapt a
video gift yes re good so when you adapt
a game to a film you lose the
interactivity and you gain mmm I hear
your arguments which your which
arguments thinking and the I think what
you you would say is that you gain a the
ability to have a full cinematic
experience that is only ever going to be
disjointed inside of a video game
because a video game the narrative is
always just by the nature of the
properties or the nature of the of the
genre is always going to be broken up by
you know this puzzle solving segment or
this fight scene that has to happen or
all these other pieces whereas a film
can condense those segments and give you
a nice clear narrative flow and share a
story with you within this universe that
doesn't take 20 hours for you to
experience and so so maybe if I'm too to
paraphrase so maybe what you're saying
is potentially you gain better cohesion
and a tighter yep experience yes and
ideally a new perspective on this
particular universe maybe because in a
video game you're locked in usually to
the character that you're playing a film
has the ability to show you things from
multiple perspectives not that games
can't but they usually don't you can
give us a perspective of another
character you can you know move the
camera around you can do you know there
are lots of things you can do with the
film that I don't think would that don't
necessarily fit as well inside of a
video game and and not to say if they
haven't been tried they have we more
done you know um you know a lot of the
things I'm talking about they've done in
games but i think that film the nature
film allows these kinds of nice
narrative flows there are so many people
that are never going to touch you know
all right they're never going to pick up
a controller and spend time in
assassin's creed or Bioshock or you know
in hundreds of other games you know if
you're talking at the numbers of console
players versus number of people that
actually go to a feature film you know
instead of a theater if it's successful
and people will be able to be a part of
this world that otherwise have really no
idea or don't care once the film studios
figure out how to do this they're going
to go home Wow oh there's like a whole
ton like a lot of these mm-hmm there's
like thousands of games well here's what
I will grant as skeptical as I am about
them ever actually cracking if they do
comic book movies better be watching
over their shoulder yes yes yeah oh I i
yes that I I will not argue with it all
and I am hopeful I mean I and I think
that there are some properties that
maybe you know we will never see again
in a video game format right half life
I'm looking at you oh and and maybe the
next best way for us to experience that
property is going to be in a film hmm
and and so I have to be hopeful that's
you know that film will work as a medium
for telling these stories we will get a
good we will get a great movie based on
a video game eventually how long do you
think is going to take five years I
would say 10 we we will see and honestly
you point out some things that I hadn't
thought so I still don't think you're
right I wouldn't want you to welcome
that's never gonna happen um but what
did you think about this whole
conversation so if you are watching the
YouTube video you can listen to the the
unedited complete except i might cut
that one thing um version of this
conversation on the Council of geeks
podcast you can find it on iTunes and
stitcher don't forget to Like subscribe
check out council of geeks twitter i
counsel the geeks you can email me
council of geeks at gmail com Paul you
want to plug anything real quick you can
find my
work list everywhere you know if you
look at the clouds and you see them you
like them that's just just say thanks
Paul to say thank you and your welcome
so I'm the lead writer out a comic book
called armadillo justice for rising sun
comics and I'm also a writer with Ryan
Daley one of our frequent contributors
to the Council of geeks one fun thing
you actually no doubt and he were the co
writers on red and green which is a
three panel or at this point nine panel
comic you can also find on rising sun
comics well thanks for joining me pollen
thank you for watching or listening or
however you chose to invite this
particular little nip so until next time
this council is adjourned